can two kid chefs beat an adult chef
in a cooking competition
[Music]
we'll see
hi i'm remy and i'm olivia and we were
on season six of masterchef junior
we've done catering before we catered
rideau showers a wedding but
tommy's the first adult we've like yeah
professionally competed against
i'm tommy walton i'm a fashion designer
but i'm also
a chef i was on masterchef season 6
7 9 and most recently 10.
hello hi hey
you are too cute you're so glamorous
tommy's someone from the show that we've
always wanted to meet
because we love all the creative dishes
he's made seeing
remy and olivia in person absolutely
terrifying i know that they are highly
skilled i'm just happy to be in his
presence too
he's just like a big like sparkle he
just lights up the room and i'm excited
to see what he makes
i don't consider myself a pastry chef
and i know
olivia and remy are highly skilled
so my competition is for me job now
whatever happens
with us in this cook-off i will forever
be yours
so the food just came to our door like a
surprise mystery box
well there's bananas and there's
chocolate and strawberries cereal
sugar flour some staples and we got some
mint
too which i love so automatically we had
some ideas on what we could make we had
to think kind of fast so
we thought strawberry shortcake would be
a good summertime
dessert i mean who doesn't love
strawberry shortcake one of my signature
masterchef dishes is bananas foster
so i think i'm gonna do something like
that
three two one
let's go okay what are you cooking it's
for us to know and you to find out
anyone from masterchef is not to be
played with watch out for the vaughn
sisters
this looks good to you look yeah that
looks really good remy
we put these very nice lights nice
bananas in this hot pan with some sugar
and the sugar is gonna caramelize
i'm gonna chop some strawberries so good
okay i have to stop eating the food
now what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna put
some sugar on top of them so
the strawberries get all their juices
out i'm gonna paint my chocolate into
this mold
and it's gonna make a chocolate shell
really easy and fun to
do so i just take a paintbrush with my
melted chocolate
okay now i'm craving chocolate i'm
getting chocolate first to eat we need
the energy
and i'm gonna pop that in the freezer
and it's gonna get hard
it will take lightning speed and
hyper planning to be able to pull off
any of this
and the amount of time that we have
specified to cook
i noticed olivia and remy looking very
relaxed
and tasting their dessert which sent me
into a total panic
if we just work quick and efficiently we
can do it
just making a couple more of these now
we're just going to add a little bit on
top
and how's that looking to you really
that looks really good okay i swear this
wasn't on top
real good now we're gonna throw this in
the oven
and bake it a few years ago
we went to morocco and they had orange
zest and orange oil in
everything so i know i add it to
pancakes waffles
and i'm adding it to this cut it up a
little extra because
i recently got tooth surgery so
working on it tommy how's it going white
chocolate yum i've got some cream here
with frosted flakes in it
and i'm gonna make christina toasty
whipped cream so i'm piping in my
chocolate shells
some whipped cream some caramelized
banana
strawberry pastry cream i've got some
strawberry
on that toast and look what i'm gonna do
i take this and i'm gonna put it right
down look at that so there we have it
it's sealed
okay our strawberries are almost done
and let's check on
this oh these are the finished biscuits
so these are all cooled and we're about
to cut them and
start putting together our strawberry
shortcake
[Music]
a little sandwich it's gonna puree
strawberries up the pipette
is filled with the strawberry puree
fruit loops
freeze-dried strawberries pulverize them
and make a powder
oh is that an immersion blender i
thought if i danced around
and made a lot of noise olivia and remy
could have a chance of getting
distracted
maybe of course
i dropped my food processor off the side
of the counter but luckily for me
i always bounced back from a disaster so
i had extra put them in a ziploc baggie
and
pulverized them by hand okay so right
now what we're doing is we're just gonna
cut
our biscuit in half so then we can fill
it with our amazing fillings
okay so we're gonna put our whipped
cream on top and sometimes
i like to do is i like to use actual
whole vanilla beans
i just think it makes it taste ten times
better and i'm gonna add some pecans on
top we can experiment with different
things
so tommy how's it going i think it's
going okay
so here's a little decor and
i have my name done in laser-cut acrylic
so look at what i do i just take my
little sign
right off like that how many minutes do
we have we've got 10 seconds
yikes come on come on come on
pressure's on longest 10 seconds of my
[Music]
life
liv and i made our biscuit that we
baked and our fresh cream with some
orange zest
and our mint toppings on top and then
garnished with
pecans and some candied strawberries it
looks great
and it's so tall the biscuit looks
delicious
pecans my mother will love you
we'll have to swap biscuit recipes so i
made several things
bananas foster toasted sandwich on a
stick
there is a chocolate banana bomb
a little picnic sandwich a strawberry
bomb
ah yum so good
so many amazing dishes like a million
different things kind of intimidating
but it was just really inspiring because
tommy
kind of does it all
i think everything comes together
beautifully the cream goes really well
with the biscuits and the strawberries
are just sweet enough to kind of tie
everything together
classic dessert that i feel like i would
order at a restaurant
very well done yeah i keep i want to eat
more of it okay
there is a lot of food
i love this i love this this is so
innovative this one
actually works together really well
there's just a little bit of banana and
cream on the inside i believe
i feel like this is something that i
would be buying at disney you know both
of these entries were really really good
i really don't think i was expecting to
eat that many
different types of things personally if
it was just one dish i would have given
it to the first one
but there was so much genius going on in
that second entry that i feel like they
should be deemed as the winners so
congratulations
your food looked incredible in the end
like doesn't really
matter who wins cooking alongside tommy
was just really cool
all of us are winners and i'm gonna have
to say
to olivia and remy congratulations to
you too
because i know what you did also
liv and i are really messy chefs and i
looked over at tommy's station
it was kind of messy too so i felt kind
of connected
you